i would probably like to open source my
avatar so there could be like millions
of lexus walking around just like an
army like agent smith agent smith yeah
exactly
uh so the uh
the unity ml folks built a copy of me
and they sent it to me
so there's a there's a person running
around and i just been doing
reinforcement learning on it i was gonna
release it
now
because you know just to have
sort of like uh thousands of lexus doing
uh reinforcements so they fall over
naturally they have to learn how to like
walk around and stuff so i love that
idea this tension between biometric
security you want to have one identity
but then certain avatars you might have
to have
many
i don't know which is better security
sort of uh flooding the world with lexus
and thereby achieving security or really
being protective of your identity i i
have to ask a security question actually
how does flooding the world with lexus
help me know in our conversation that
i'm talking to the real ex i completely
destroy the trust in all my
relationships then right if i flood
because then
it's yeah that um
i think that one's not going to work
that well for you it's not going to work
that way i mean for the original
it probably fits some things like if
you're a public figure and you're trying
to
have
you know a bunch of
if you're trying to show up in a bunch
of different places in the future you'll
be able to do that in the metaverse so
that kind of replication i think will be
useful but i do think you're gonna want
a notion of like
i am talking to the real one
yeah
yeah especially if the if the fake ones
start outperforming you and all your
private relationships and then you're
left behind i mean that's that's a
serious concern i have with clones again
the things i think about
you